you know this is like playing golf it's
simple hit the ball put it in the hole
so all you got to do here is just follow
the instruction drive the right speed
and then just make the turns where they
tell you that's all there is to it but
just like Gulf doing it well it can be
really difficult it it takes expertise
it takes time it takes effort takes
practice and by the way you have to do
more than one great race before you get
very good generally but all of you
rookies in the room have a huge
advantage onslaught of the rest of us
you can win this year only as a rookie
so this is your big shot go for it win
your money this year you get up in the
next division it gets tougher and then
it gets tougher after that i'm not
starting to rethink my efforts on
training rookies because i'm finding the
rookies are moving up into the sportsman
class and then they're competing against
this and they're better than we are i
helped train to specific rookie teams
last year and they both beat us so we
broke down okay all right we're going to
talk about 4 s's today and you can ask
questions as we go along I'll try and
cover them I may move ahead a bit so
that we can cover the subject a little
later but i'll try and get to all your
questions there's 4 s's that you need to
understand the 4 s's our safety first
start on time stay on course and stay on
time if you're a rookie your main focus
for today and tomorrow needs to be on
the first three safety first starting on
time and staying on course we're going
to talk about time Corrections and so on
today don't pay too much attention to
those today you can start working on
those tomorrow in the next few days okay
all right do we have any questions about
how to picking up your course
instructions and getting started today
or tomorrow John covered that pretty
thoroughly I will tell you one new piece
of information Steve and Vicki who hand
out your course instructions will have a
digital WWV time calibration clock some
place near the canopy today so when you
leave here you can go calibrate your
clock and your stopwatch out front they
will have that where you pick up your
course instructions every morning so you
and you should calibrate or check your
clock and or your stopwatch every
morning so you make sure you are on the
same time as all the course workers are
on so you can do that and you can do it
at any time you don't have to wait till
it's your turn to pick up your course
instructions you can do it at any time
walk out there and check it you can also
check your ear clocks you can go to the
time gov on the internet and you can get
the time standard there and you can
calibrate against that any questions our
actors is a cell phone man
the clock out I've heard people tell me
different stories about that I trust the
one out front that's what John and his
crews are using so you there's other
methods take your take your chance I
like the one out front good okay she
says the phone call with a call to WWV
number he's always as good as the one we
have out front but she always double
checks it to against the one out front
you know it's this whole thing trust but
verify I trust the phone call I'm going
to verify it with john's number all
right you're going to talk about safety
for a minute no score is worth an
accident we tell everybody to drive safe
all the speeds are below the speed limit
even if you have to make up time you
should be able to do it with within the
speed limit don't do something that's
unsafe even though you will be sorely
tempted at times you made a wrong turn
you got back in line and yours five cars
out of position and your temptation is
to go like a bat whatever and pass the
next five cars and get back in position
we've all done it you will do it but
safety first if you don't make it if you
have to can't drive fast enough to do it
if you're breaking speed limits be very
careful no score is worth an accident we
don't want to get anybody hurt on this
so being very careful for you drivers
when you're driving on the course if you
see cars that are coming up behind you
that are trying to pass you trying to
get back in position be courteous to
them but it is their problem not yours
okay they need to find a safe place to
pass you and to get in front you can run
your own race they made the mistake they
have to take the
consequences there's time delays we will
talk about time delays here in a little
bit for situations beyond your control
you can take a time allowance you cannot
take a time allowance for your flat tire
the fact you slept in in the morning and
started late the fact you got lost and
had to go turn around and come back no
you cannot do that if a combine pulls
out in front of you and does 10 miles an
hour for the next three miles down the
road and there's no way you can pass him
and or make up the time you can take a
time allowance for that that was beyond
your control if if your distributor
breaks and takes you 30 minutes on the
side of the road to fix it that was
within your control you should have
fixed it before he got here yes if it's
something where it's impossible if you
had to sit there for 10 seconds make it
up you sit there for five minutes and
you can't proceed because it's unsafe
you can take time allowance let's get
started on time the second s and one of
the most important if you do not start
on time at that restart point in the
field if you're a minute late and don't
know it all the good corners and stop
signs and all the saints won't help if
you're a minute off and often people get
started and a minute off and don't know
they're a minute off and if you don't
know it you've just proceed in in
ignorance so make sure you get started
on time and the key time point on this
rally today is that instruction right
after lunch is his instruction 26 so no
matter when you pick up your
instructions in the morning and when you
get your speedo check done and all those
things when you come to that second
digital clock of the day
that's the one where you have to be
precisely on time picking up
instructions in the morning you will
normally get them 30 minutes before your
scheduled start time when you pick up
your instructions you do not have to
wait until your scheduled time in this
case the scheduled time is 1130 you
would have picked up your instructions
on a normal day at starting at eleven
o'clock plus your car position start
position you do not have to sit there
for at the hotel for that 30 minutes you
can leave at any time after you get your
course instructions but I suggest that
you pick up your course instructions and
do a couple of things first off count
the pages it is really bad news at two
o'clock in the afternoon you find out
the page 26 is missing there's nothing
you can do so count your pages as soon
as you get your instructions there could
be a printing or assembly error make
sure you got them all secondly in our
car we start to do a couple things will
spend ten minutes sitting in the hotel
lobby or something and we'll start to
work on the course instructions we have
to punch three holes and top of ours to
get them on our clipboard so we do that
as we count the pages then we go through
and write start writing a couple things
on we picked that we look at every page
and write this correct speed at the top
of every page from the page before so
when you look at the bottom of page 5
you're doing 20 miles an hour right 20
at the top of page six do that on every
page do this so you do not have to flip
pages back and forth you're up over here
on page six and you're coming heading
towards that stop sign and it might be
two miles that stop sign you forgot what
speed you're supposed to be driving you
have to flip the page back to see you
write it up to top the page if an
instruction like instruction 35 if the
speed of 30 of 25 is not written there
then right in the speed from this
previous instruction if that hole is
blank so there's a couple things you can
do before you ever leave within get in
the car take ten minutes and do those
kind of things there's another thing
that you need to do very early if you
look at the top of page six and look at
instruction 34 what's the hint say on
column D on 34 comes quick so you're
finishing 33 on the previous page and
you're working along is you got some
errors you're trying to calculate how
you did at that stop sign you finally
turn the page oh my goodness that came
very quick that one you'll probably find
it was another stop sign but it might
not be a stop sign it might be a turn
that comes very quick and you will have
missed it because you were sitting there
looking at the page before if you see it
comes quick highlight those comes quick
in the right hand column column D and if
the top of a page make yourself a big
note on the page before to make sure you
get that page turned really quickly and
so you know what's coming on the top of
the next page how many veterans here
have been caught by that okay we bought
by the way there's eighty three separate
mistakes you can make I've counted them
they read and that as they repeat at
random
what which instruction 33 okay no no it
says you're doing 20 miles an hour when
you get to the stop sign you're going to
zero yeah you've crossed off one error
already you're down to 82 more to make
let's start talk about starting line
John talked about starting lined out in
the field when you get it out to
instruction toys 26 where you're going
to start on time you will get there
early at 26 probably there'll be 10 to
20 cars sitting there find a safe place
to wait away from the action you can
watch the other cars go after the car in
front of you has left its now you're a
minute you can pull up to the start
position and you can sit there and wait
until it's your exact time to go and you
can pull out and go the car in front of
you isn't there don't go a minute early
sit there and wait until it's your time
to go now there's an issue with dash
clocks dash clocks have the the minute
hands lead when they go down on the
right side and they like when they go up
on the other side and the minute hand is
often between two numbers just a tip we
use we use the time of day on our stop
watch to make sure we're on the absolute
right minute you can do that and then
you can switch your stopwatch back to
its normal function leave on time now
and there's nobody at that start line to
tell you when to go is your total
responsibility to know when to leave of
course
case where the car ahead of you has
missed this time with something and so
he's going to affect your time starting
if the car in front of you is missed his
time and shows up late he has a problem
he needs to allow you to go when you're
supposed to go know if the car in front
of you sits there and doesn't go pull up
around him and leave on your minute I've
seen this happen where somebody thought
it was his minute to go he pulled up and
he decided to go anyway then he find him
a mile down the road stopping and
waiting event to get back on time let's
talk about sign terminology and
communication in the car you and your
navigator need to find a way of
communicating that is clear and concise
and conveys the information that you
need to convey if you don't do that and
start talking about other things you
will miss a sign if my navigator if my
navigator my bride of 50 years says
we're looking for a hard left 25 I know
exactly what that sign looks like I
don't have to see thats I'll see it on
the road but I know what I'm looking for
is the driver saw item 35 is a hard left
25 not a soft left 25 it's not just a
hard right it's a hard right or hard
left 25 now some place in here there was
a snake where's the snake 56 there's a
snake sign it's a snake sign all right
but it's a very specific snake sign
that's sign happens to be a snake left
20 it's not a snake right 20 it's a
snake left 20 okay because the first
turn on that sign goes to the left so
you need to be that kind of specific
when you're communicating in our car we
use a kind of symbolic symbols called
ice which stands for identify confirm
execute the navigator will tell us what
we're looking for we're looking for
that hard left 25 we will start seeing
yellow signs that one's the possibility
no that's not it and one of us will say
that's it I see it the other one will
say I see it too confirmed then the
navigator at that point can looked out
the instructions and make sure that we
know what to do at that sign because the
driver now knows where the sign is and
sees it the navigator will then say at
that hard left 25 you're going to change
speeds to 20 miles an hour or whatever
you're going to do and confirms to the
driver what you're to do when you reach
that sign then after we leave the sign I
will say to my navigator I'm holding
whatever speed I'm holding 20 and she
will immediately say no you idiot you're
supposed to be doing 25 that's good
communication yeah but she tells you
what to do and then you do it and
confirm it back that what you're doing
and then the navigator should often down
the road every few minutes say you're
doing 40 or you're doing this and just
checking what you're doing or the driver
can communicate what he's doing that we
used to say that you can tell the
drivers because they had bruises on
their right arm because the navigator
would say we're doing 40 we're doing 40
we're doing 40 dammit I said do 40 so a
a safety item when you're on the course
the drivers the I used to call them
civilians and somebody reminded me be
more appropriate to call them
non-participants non-participants in the
rally we're always driving about five
miles an hour below the speed limit most
non participants are driving five miles
an hour above the speed limit okay so
they're going to start piling up on your
may pile up on your bumper usually
there's not much traffic but they may
pile up on your bumper when you come to
that hard
left 25 sign they expect you to take
your foot off the gas and slow down even
more but no we great racers don't do
that what do we do when we get that sign
we nail the brakes the last thing that
car behind you expects you to do if you
have cars behind you get your hand out
the window wave them back get them to
slow down give them some space so you
don't get hit work as a team weather no
matter if your navigator makes all the
errors its team errors and takes a team
to fix them after you make the mistake
work together as a team cross off your
instructions as you complete them I'm
sure we will have some place during this
rally over nine days where we will have
two identical instructions in a row the
worst thing in the world is going to do
one of them the second worst in the
world is to do it three times instead of
twice so cross them off in our car I
will sometimes look over at the
instruction sheet because it's in a
place where I can see it is the
navigators busy doing something else and
i forget what to do i will look over
there and so I can see what the next
instruction is without bothering the
navigator when you come to a stop sign a
good technique on a stop sign you're
going to be timing your paws times
probably to stop sign you will come up
to a stop sign the driver will stop the
navigator starts to stop watch the
navigator will say we're going to turn
left on 88 seconds if that's the correct
pause time and then by the time she says
that she's already at four seconds on
the watch and she will say four five six
seven go the last word is always go
because the driver forgot when he was
supposed to go even though he heard it
four seconds earlier he's watching
traffic or something so use I think you
should always count up rather than down
count up to the time you're going to go
use go is the last or then
the driver accelerates away from the
stop sign navigators remind him again
how fast he's supposed to leave the stop
sign because he forgot that too so as he
pulls out and says you're going to 40
and he'll know exactly what speed to go
to all right if you do all those things
stay on the course start on time you
will have a good rally of this afternoon
and tomorrow you'll do pretty good and
by Sunday you'll start to get frustrated
because your scores aren't looking quite
as good as you think you can do so we're
going to talk about how to handle time
changes time shifts time allowances we
got about 20 minutes and we should be
finished so everybody can leave on time
stop signs John allows you 15 seconds at
a stop sign tells you to pause but he
assumes you can stop instantly and start
instantly some of the cars even though
we got Corvettes and some other cars we
got to Plymouth of the 426 Hemi in it in
the race and so on they even they can't
do that so you need to stop for less
time so you can allow for the
acceleration or the deceleration and the
acceleration time and that's where your
car calibration chart comes in handy
we've given you one in the books you
received and we handed them out today
and there's a stop chart on there and
you can look at the end time for the
speed you're approaching the
intersection and then go across to the
the speed where you're leaving the
intersection and it will tell you how
long to pause instead of the 8.6 seconds
or 15 seconds it says pause for 8.6
seconds you're probably not going to be
able to handle tenths of a second
rounded off to the nearest whole second
and go on those times if you didn't make
your own chart and you're using our
charts for a 36 Packard just drive like
a 36 pack
the guys in the 426 Hemi used our chart
in Joplin a few weeks ago and they
thought it worked fine so I guess you
can do it better to make your own chart
you can do that for next year for a turn
but if you do the stop sign correctly
when you come out of the stop sign you
will be back on time well let's say you
stop a new posi eight seconds and your
driver doesn't go because he's got
oncoming traffic or a problem and he
sits there let the watch run and stop
the watch what he does decide to go
finally and then subtract your eight
seconds he was supposed to be stopped he
stopped for 15 you're now seven seconds
behind and you'll need to make up the
seven seconds if he in some cases the
driver may leave early because he saw a
spot in traffic and there were two
18-wheelers coming so he jumped out in
front he was supposed to go on eight he
went on six now you're two seconds too
fast and you'll have to lose some time
down the road when you have adjustments
in time to make make those adjustments
fairly quickly the first opportunity you
have make them up do not carry them
forward from one page to the next and so
on sure enough heck checkpoint will show
up and you'll be in trouble so make them
up don't carry them forward corners we
use the chart the same way you read your
in speed you read your out speed and
that intersection on the chart will tell
you how many seconds have lost net loss
you have on the corner and that will be
a net loss you always lose speed on a
corner and horse Jeff for that oh he got
up he was just here and bless you
quarter like Jeff for debt in the yellow
30 to pick up but normally what what we
do and the chart is based on this one's
we've given you we slow to 15 miles an
hour at the apex to the cars shift gears
and accelerate out that's what that
art is based on you can make your own
chart you can do it differently there's
more advanced techniques for corners and
we're not going to talk about that here
you can ask the veterans about that when
you're when you're ready for it but so
you will have a net loss coming out of a
corner now let's talk about one more
thing i'll tell you about makeup times
let's find a speed change let's talk
about let's talk about 35 first ok let's
look at instruction 35 you're doing 40
miles an hour in instruction 34 and
you're going to go to 25 miles an hour
when you come to instruction 25 or 35 so
how do you make that speed change what
you want to do is break smoothly and
consistently across that sign so you
cross the sign at half the speed between
the two speeds so in this case it's
going to be what thirty two and a half
miles an hour so you want to be doing
thirty two and a half miles per hour at
that sign as you're slowing between 40
and 25 and is very smooth steady fashion
don't wait until the sign and then start
breaking or don't break ahead of time
before you get to the sign and get all
the way to the speed before the sign do
what we call splitting the sign split to
speed across the sign if you need to air
a little bit to get it right air on
breaking a little too early especially
if it's a very large speed change you'll
be more accurate doing it that way if
questions on how to split a sign you do
the same thing going up exactly the same
thing and somebody asked me yesterday
well how do I know when to start
breaking I said break so you're exactly
halfway between the two speeds when you
go across the sign where is that it's at
the point where you will be exactly
halfway between the two speeds
you get the sign how will I know that as
a driver of practice for you to do is
you note figure out the half speed in
your mind before you get that point and
glanced at the sign watch the sign go by
and watch your speedometer and see how
close you hit it you can tell and you
can watch it and you'll get better and
better at doing speed splits if you do
those right you won't have any lost time
ok now you've come around that corner
and your navigator says you're down 3.6
seconds after you came around the corner
and we need to make that up we make that
up using the ten percent rule the ten
percent yesterday is doing a rookie
seminar and if we're going through some
of this on the board and so on you can
see all the people looking oh we're back
to sixth grade algebra or something here
I've got to figure this out it's not
hard you can do it in your head a ten
percent rule is take the error and
multiply it by 10 so if you've got a 3.6
second error you need to make up
multiply it by 10 that's 36 go ten
percent faster for those 36 seconds if
you're doing 30 miles an hour go to 33
miles an hour do that for the 36 seconds
and slow down and you'll be back on time
you can do that for any amount you can
do it up or down 10 10 times the error
go ten percent faster for that amount of
time and you'll be back on time another
good formula this one's a little more
complex another good one to know is if
you come up behind a school bus and you
have to drive 30 instead of 40 for 30
seconds you there's a formula for
calculating that it's in the books that
we sent to all the rookies but basically
take the difference in speed divide it
by the correct speed and multiply that
times your seconds so if you were to go
instead of 40 for 30 seconds take the 30
/ the 40 or take 10 I'm sorry the
difference in speed take 10 / the 40
times your seconds that's one-fourth of
the seconds and if it was 30 seconds it
would be seven and a half seconds that
you're then need to make up let's talk
about transit zones let's go to line 39
the most common mistakes rookies make
are on transit zones so we've got to
make sure we know how to do a transit
zone properly and by the way if you go
more than half a day without knowing
what you're doing stop ask somebody the
first gas brake you got go up to any
veteran anybody and they will tell you
tell I don't understand line such as I
what was I supposed to do back there
they will tell you that's why you have
the red hats and the red nametags is so
that we know who the rookies are and we
will anybody will help you don't keep
going without understanding what you're
doing it just adds misery to the trip
and it's a lot more fun when you know
how to do it alright let's look at line
39 when you cross that stop ahead sign
at line 39 you need to write down the
time of day my navigator puts in the
column D will put dash dash dash both on
her course instructions before we leave
before we start the day she'll put that
there and under that she'll write plus
25 and then when we get to that stop
ahead sign we record the time of day
either off our stopwatch or off the dash
clock and she writes that time in and as
soon as we stop that during this transit
she adds those two numbers together and
transfers them down to line 45
she will already put a dash dot dash dot
dot lying there so she knows that that
goes there and she immediately transfers
that don't go to the bathroom don't get
out of the car until you know what that
departure time is and when you get out
of the car to go to the John because the
last race we were on they had separate
men's and women's restrooms you will go
different directions you need to know
when you need to be back in the car
ready to go in this case notice that the
yeah it takes 10 minutes to get from the
restroom to that recert point at 45 I
have seen very long transits where it
was not intended for you to take a
bathroom break or refuel you thought you
could do it there were places you could
do it and you stopped it went to the
bathroom fill the car with fuel and you
got back out and said it is 45 minutes
to get from where you are to the restart
point and you've used up all the time
going to the bathroom some transits are
just intended to get you someplace not
intended for you to take a break so make
sure you know how long it's going to
take you to get to that restart point
when you get to line 45 and you've got
your time to go the cars will no longer
be a minute apart you may be perfect but
the cars in front of you and the car
behind you will not be perfect you will
not be living on one minute intervals
you will be spaced at some other spacing
maybe a few seconds apart it may be
minutes apart so just watch that so when
you pull up to that start point at that
speed limit 25 or that 25 corner marker
sign just be aware when you pull up
there you may not have a full minute
there may be two or three of you trying
to leave within that same minute at that
point one thing that John didn't mention
as you saw note I made we will cross
of time zones on this rally the practice
has been in the past every day stays in
one time zone as far as our timing is
concerned you may physically cross into
a different time zone but your clocks
and everything stay on this time zone
you started in the morning John will
probably be more specific on that in the
instructions but that we've had that
question come up time allowances at the
back of your instructions there will be
two sheets attached every day for a time
allowance sheet they should be
self-explanatory we talked a little bit
about when you can use them in when you
can't when you get a chance when you
stop fill those out make a note in your
margin of your instructions when it
occurred how much time it was and then
fill out the form you must turn the form
in at the first read checkpoint
typically that's going to be at lunch
and when you end the day if there
happened to be an emergency red sign out
along the route someplace you would turn
it in there at a red checkpoint sign
you're allowed to stop before the red
checkpoint sign if you see there's a red
checkpoint and you haven't fill out the
form stop fill it out proceed up to the
red sign and and turn it in with a green
check point John didn't mention you
cannot stop within sight of a chuck
greene checkpoint in fact you cannot go
slower than five miles an hour so just
make sure you don't do that okay
specific questions that we got
will always be after lunch is always a
time of day restart just like the
morning so if you broke down in the
morning and you're running an hour late
because you had to fix a flat tire and
you had to do something else you may
miss lunch because you got to get back
to that start time after lunch well the
rally seminar must have helped till
yesterday they're always be a checkpoint
before lunch it Darrell there will
always be a checkpoint in the morning
will it be right before lunch not
necessarily you will get good at trying
to guess where checkpoints are let me
give you a hint when you get the let's
look at the end of the day here where's
the end of the day okay you get to 61
let's say you had a checkpoint some
place back around 58 58 or 59 you have a
checkpoint and you say we made it we got
through who've been through four
checkpoints we're done for the day all
we gots one more stop sign and so on and
we're out of here follow the
instructions all the way till the end of
the course they may throw a checkpoint
in three minutes later or ten minutes
later don't get anxious and jump the gun
at the end of the day run it out same
thing before lunch don't assume the
emergency rent scoffs and kind of hassle
if there's an emergency star any red
stop if it's an emergency you're off the
clock okay so that whole leg could be
gone else it could be yeah that leg
could be thought they will tell you what
to do that they would if they tell you
got a certain time and do this and get
to this place they will tell you what to
do you don't have to worry about that
instruction says stop you stop and that
they will let you know what to do all
right let's have a safe rally I think
Saturn
night we have a what did I do wrong John
Classen and I will be there and we will
take you through whatever questions you
have at that time you guys probably
won't make any mistakes the first day so
you won't have any questions he won't be
back in yet